il y a eu et vous allez voir ça va
continuer il y a eu des articles qui
disent oui ils ont fêté
les 2 millions de téléspectateurs ils
ont fêté les audiences de TPMP alors
qu'il parlaient du drame de Lola et donc
il y a énormément voilà il y a des
journalistes qui disent oui c'est une
admissible enfin c'est inadmissible donc
ils disent n'importe quoi c'est comme si
bfn demain se félicite des audiences de
la chaîne il parle de drame tous les
jours et on va dire ah bah tant BFM il
traite que de drame mais il félicite de
leurs audiences bon voilà donc
sachez que ça nous aide énormément
touché ce genre d'attaque et toutes les
équipes parce que bien entendu on a été
bouleversé parce qu'il s'est passé par
le meurtre atroce de l'Olympe et voir
encore de la récupération pour faire des
articles putaclic et autres parce qu'il
y a des gros journaux qui sont post etc
parisien ça a démarré sur des gens sur
Twitter qui veulent faire parler d'eux
essayer de faire parler d'eux sur ce
drame
franchement c'est mais si au-delà du
pitoyable c'est vraiment horrible et
c'est vraiment se servir de ça pour
essayer de beser de nous taper dessus et
d'essayer de faire des articles derrière
pour être encore plus lui et faire de la
[ __ ] à clique je vous dis pour moi c'est
être les pires des crapules
et ça je vous le dis ceux qui ont fait
des articles sur ça et qui continuent à
le faire et je le dis au téléspectateurs
pour moi c'est une honte et il faut
vraiment le dénoncer
c'est vraiment horrible c'est pas des
journalistes c'est pas des journalistes
puisque si tu sais s'il y a des
journalistes qui reprennent non mais
c'est pas ils se disent journaliste mais
c'est pas des raisons
il y a deux heures d'écart c'est pas du
tout la même émission celle-ci sa tête
on sait qu'on déconne qu'on rigole et
ensuite c'est la fin de toute façon
c'est une émission
de fouetter des audiences qui sont
bonnes parce que on traitait
voilà en fait toutes les au fait tout et
puis on fait les missions et puis
surtout une émission de divertissement
et je vous le dis ici on a été et comme
toute la France très très touché parce
qu'il s'est passé
sur Lola je vous le dis moi ma mère elle
me dit tous les jours elle endort pas de
cette affaire depuis depuis la semaine
dernière
on essaie de vous informer le plus
possible et pourquoi on parle énormément
de cette affaire aussi parce qu'on veut
pas que ça se reproduise
on en a marre de ça voilà on est comme
vous on en a marre de voir des drames on
l'a dit je l'ai dit hier en ministre de
l'intérieur on en peut plus de voir des
drames des choses qu'on ne voyait pas
avant des choses inadmissibles et quand
des abrutis ce sont des abrutis encore
je suis gentil quand je les abrutis se
servent de ça et de ce drame pour faire
des vues sur le sur le net et vendre
leurs journaux
en servant de ce drame et en nous tapant
dessus c'est franchement c'est ignoble
et eux ce sont vraiment sont des gens
pour moi on doit leur enlever leur carte
de presse voilà je vous le dis oui non
mais c'est des rageux des gens jaloux et
gris qui font des raccourcis
dégueulasses en plus parce que
évidemment enfin déjà je sais pas
comment on peut avoir l'esprit tordu
personne ne pensait à ça quand vous avez
fait la fête parce que c'était voilà
pour fêter en plus les audiences de
l'émission sur un mois et évidemment que
l'émission sur trois heures vous avez
différentes manières de traiter les
sujets quand vous traitez le sachet le
sujet de Lola vous faites avec dignité
dans le respect et quand vous faites la
fête vous faites la fête donc ce sont
des gens qui veulent vous nuire et oui
toutes les émissions faites leurs
audiences quand ce sont des chaînes
d'infos même que ce sont des émissions
de faits divers donc même cette attaque
là il ne tient pas c'est des gens qui
veulent juste vous nuire et c'est
dégueulasse de regarder je vois ça Télé
7 Jours
célèbre le record de nuances de TPMP et
une émission sur le meurtre de l'oeil
crée la polémique c'est dégueulasse
exactement
et en fait rien que le titre que vous
avez donné c'est significatif il surf
c'est eux qui récupèrent de manière
indigne le drame et il sort sur un
double boss quand on met TPMP Hanouna ou
Lola ils font un carton de vue c'est à
dire que il récupère de manière odieuse
ignorineuse un drame absolu pour
eux-mêmes vendre faire des vues du buzz
c'est ça qui est un digne vous avez
raison si jamais ce sont des
journalistes à carte de presse qui ont
fait ça j'espère qu'ils seront traduits
devant la commission parce que ça alors
il se sert de quelques tweets pour dire
voilà bien sûr mais ils font le titre
c'est le titre avec le titre là dessus
c'est ça qui est dégueulasse c'est ça
qui est dégueulasse donc voilà écoutez
voilà bon ça c'est je vais vous dire
c'est encore oui
immonde nous à Touche pas à mon poste on
n'a pas le droit d'en parler c'est à
dire qu'on est passé finalement bien on
n'est pas suffisamment sensible on n'a
pas suffisamment d'empathie on connaît
enfin je veux dire on connaît ni moins
bien ni mieux la société donc on est à
notre place en tant chroniqueur on en
parle et on en parle différemment et on
en parle aussi à des gens qui sont très
jeunes et qui regardent cette émission
et tant mieux d'ailleurs et donc
effectivement oui c'est assez
dégueulasse en fait non plus on connaît
l'ADN de l'émission c'est d'abord
divertissement
ils adorent pour ça et après on traite
des sujets sérieux avec 2h30 plus tard
avec dignité respect et je vais vous
dire le seul problème qu'on a
aujourd'hui et je le dis c'est que
l'émission C'est des records d'audience
et je vous le dis c'est le seul truc qui
dérange et que voilà ça dérange
énormément de monde mais nous on
continuera à être droit dans nos bottes
à vous enfermer à vous divertir et je
vous dire tant que les abrutis ont-ils
en ont à faire des tweets et à faire des
articles c'est que tout va bien
sachez-le c'est que vraiment tout va
bien c'est que on est sur la bonne voie
j'ai pas vu je n'ai pas vu un
journaliste Twitter sur nos audiences
c'est ça qui est magnifique alors j'ai
vu plein de Rives qui twittent sur les
émissions médias et il tutent sur toutes
les émissions sauf sur TPMP c'est quand
même exceptionnel et voilà et c'est le
la seule émission sur laquelle il ne
twittent pas ou sur laquelle il ne
réagissent pas voilà donc c'est encore
de la récupération et c'est c'est grave
c'est grave non franchement c'est grave
alors que si les audiences étaient
mauvaises c'est sûr qu'ils auraient ils
ont ils ont ils en ont parlé exactement
oui non mais c'est oui c'est simplement
de la jalousie parce que aujourd'hui il
y a personne qui fait ça du divers soit
c'est des gens qui font du
divertissement pur soit c'est des gens
qui font de l'information et du et du
sociétal et vous faites les deux donc
voilà mais juste on essaie de nous
mettre un bad buzz sur le dos mais le
bad buzz pour moi il est vraiment pour
eux de faire ça c'est vraiment
horrible c'est vraiment un énorme bad
buzz c'est c'est indigne et puis chérie
on fêtera toujours les missions en début
d'émission on fait toujours on danse on
rigole on chante il y a le président qui
est venu qui a fait une entrée et c'est
vrai voilà c'est tout pour fêter les
autres c'est pour fêter oui pour fêter
les audiences que ce soit l'audience du
jour ou l'audience de depuis le début de
l'année on l'a refait le lendemain voilà
et on continuera le faire avec ton
capitaux qui est un président incroyable
qui qui joue le jeu voilà et si je vous
dis c'est alors ça veut dire je vous dis
c'est comme si on reprochait à BFM TV
qui va certainement faire communiquer
sur ses audiences incroyables là ils
l'ont vu l'ont fait ils le font tous les
jours en
Ukraine exactement
ils ont le droit de le faire mais bien
sûr sauf qu'on fait pas de des articles
sur FNTE exactement pour parler pour
dire que BFM a communiqué sur les
audiences alors qu'ils traitent que de
que que de drame voilà donc les
émissions de cet univers parlent aussi
de leurs hommes bien sûr ça marche bien
faites entrer l'accusé qui font des
cartons d'audience ils le disent le
lendemain
c'est de la jalousie et on vous fait
aussi un procès en illégitimité comme si
on avait pas le droit de traiter de
sujet et aussi Cyril il faut dire aussi
que vous gênez beaucoup à cause de vos
audiences à cause de l'émission Face à
babac avec Monsieur Darmanin beaucoup de
gens ont jalousé donc chez les bobos
c'est les journalistes qui se pré dans
la sphère politique aussi qui n'existe
pas
bien sûr le problème sinon c'est qu'il
n'existe pas
voilà n'existe pas mais les gens ils
sont pas cons ils ont très bien compris
qu'au début on rigole ils ont très bien
compris qu'il y avait le 6 à 7 qui avait
Touche pas à mon poste en jaune ils ont
très bien compris quand ça passe en bleu
avant à 20h45 21h ils sont pas con les
gens ils écoutent pas ces trucs là ils
sont pas bête les gens